[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to our podcast
of the series called High School
memories my name is m and I will be your
host today so without further those let
dive into today's episode andberg on a
great journey together get ready to be
engaged entertained and inspired today's
topic will be about Prison Break is an
American television series that
originally aired from 2005 to 2009 the
show was created by Paul shine and
produced by Adin Peru Productions it
consists of Four Seasons with a total of
81 episodes Prison Break is known for
its suspenseful and action packed Soul
line the serious revols around the
eliberate and daring plan of Michael
scoffield
played by Wentworth Miller to break his
wrongly accused brother Lin buros played
by Dominic brel out of prison linol has
been sentenced to death for a crime he
did not commit the murder of the vice
president's brother determined to save
his brother from the electric chair
Michael commenced a bank robbery to get
himself in prisoned at the same poent
Fox River State pentary the first season
followed the rescue of linol BOS is
accused of murdering tereny Stedman the
brother of Vice President of the United
States colon rolds Lincoln is sentenced
to death and is
incarcerated in Fox River State pentry
where he awaits his
excusion L Lincoln's brother
brilli engineer Michael Scofield is
convinced of linc's insanes and
formulates an elaborate Escape Plan in
order to gain access to Fox server
Michael commments an armed robbery which
results in him being sentence to forx
server in prison Michael bef friends the
prison Dr Sarah
T when he pretends to
suffer from type 1 diabetes in order to
gain dily access to the prison's
infirmary where he receives his daily
installation shots the brother's fight
toward of the execution is aided by
their lifelong friend Veronica do
Donovan who begins to inv investigate
the
conspiration that put lincol in jail
however they are hindered by covert
agent members of an organization called
the company so the company was
responsible for forming linol and they
did so because of Lincoln's father ELO
burrow and his former connection with
the companies the brothers along with
six
inmates Fernando
secure Theodor TC bewell Benjamin miles
C
Franklin David twinner aulus John ab
bruzi and Charles Hayward
Pik Pik who come to be known as the Fox
River eight Escape in the season P pen m
penit m Episode by using their prison
privilege to dig an escape tunnel
underneath the prison
the second season begins 8 hours after
the Escape focusing mainly on the eight
escapes the fugitives splits up and
journey to location across the country
with
authorities cloth behind them as they
each Purge their their individual gos
Brad Bellic gets fired from the prison
where he worked at the main guard and
chases after the in imate himself for
the reward money several of The Escapist
reunit in search of a large cage of
money buried Long Ago by other Fox River
I made Charles West
Morland federal agent Alexander Mone
Mayon is assigned to track down and
capture the eight
fidget but it's revealed to be working
for the company which wants all eight
men dead when Sarah discovers her
father's Governor Frank
tankr has been killed she miss with
Michael reminding with him as the
brothers try to break down now president
rolds a company
member to en ensure the brother's safety
SAR allows herself to be arrested and
face his Trail turning the trail the
testimony of former secret service agent
Paul Colman who used to work for the
company controlled president exonerated
exonerates linol and Sarah half of
escapes are killed or
recapitate but the brothers make it to
PanAm Michael tiac and Mohan and bellik
are arrested by the
paname authoriz and
imprisoned at the
penara federal
Desa so now we are at the third season
follows Michael inside Sona and Lincoln
on the outside in Pana Panama Sona is a
prison run by the inmates and guarded
only from the outside Duo to a r the
year before iates are always supplied
with food and water and are expect to
disturb and serve fellow imates
independently the surrounding landscape
is monitored by armed guards who shots
and the who shots who shot sorry at the
side of iron ma escaping bir is quite
quickly contact by Gran Morgan a
companies operative who was in charge of
operation in Panama who kidnapped his
son LJ to break James Whistler out out
of
Sona and the season follows Michael and
wh's Tra in formulating an escape plan
as Michael has to deal with extreme
tension and as linol deals with the
company's operative GRE
Morgan skew gets a job and the prisent
to Aid Michael in his Escape Plan when
Lincoln attempts to rescue Sara and J
following a clue
proofed by Sarah gr claims to have Beed
Sarah and Sansing called ahead in a box
as a Waring as the season as the peer
managed to escape along with Mahon and
another in mate IM mate Louis leaving
behind several accomplishes including TC
and
B
secures identi identity is discovered by
a prison guard and he is threw into Sona
just after the Escape LJ and sopia who
was captured for a
grun that Whistler would go with her are
trated for Whistler and Michael seeks
revenge against gretchin forar
deaths the measure story line for the
four SE season is all about taking the
company down a team is put together the
brother secure Michael cell mate in foxy
River
prison Mayon brand Bellic Sara and
Roland Glen the teachi the team was put
together by Homeland Security agent Don
Sal this season in my opinion was the
most complex the company the reason for
so many deaths surrounding each member
of the team was finally being take down
each member had a reason to take down
the
company each member knew someone killed
by the company in order to carry out the
company's selfish plans the season ends
with the company being taken down and
just just to say just
say just say coming to those
responsible still you feel like you have
to take a deep breathe after it all
comes to a slow the ski where Michael is
at the table about to hand
over ska the companies black book and
patented ecological technology is worth
bons in exch exchange for exaggeration
you can see it it his face he's tired
just as you think it's all about to go
bad once more Michael says I'm tired for
of
running and he hands over
squa esquella his steam is
fully EX Nate and their family family
safe everything that they had been
fighting for the past for for years was
finally coming into Fu as a viewer it
felt good like taking a deep breathe
after test lugs are relaxed if you were
a watcher of the show you know how it
turns I feel like the adding is very
appra
and be
beautiful so this is all what I want to
say thank you so much for joining us on
this episode of high school memories
it's been an incred incredible journey
and we're so glad you come along for the
ride until next time take care bye
thanks for listening hope you like it
hi everyone welcome back to our podcast
on the series called High School
memories my name is m and I will be our
host today so without further Ado let
dive into today's episode and urg on a
great journey together get ready to be
engaged entertained and inspired today's
topic will be about Prison Break is an
American television series that
originally aired from 2005 to 2009 the
show was created by Paul Shing and
produced by Adin Peru Productions it
consists of Four Seasons with a total of
81 episodes Prison Break is known for
its suspensful and action packed soine
the serious revols around the elaborate
and daring plan of Michael
scoffield played by Wentworth Miller to
break his wrongly accused Brother linol
buros played by Dominic PR out of prison
linkle has been sentenced to death for a
crime he did not commit the of the vice
president's brother determined to save
his brother from the electric chair
Michael commenced a bank robbery to get
himself in prisoned at the same pentary
Fox River State pentary the first season
follows the rescue of linol baros who is
accused of murdering tereny Stedman the
brother of Vice President of the United
States col rolds Lincoln is sentenced to
death and is incurs
in Fox River State pentre where he
awaits his
excusion L Lincoln's brother brilliant
Str engineer Michael Scofield is
convinced of lol's insanes and
formulates an elaborate Escape Plan in
order to gain access to Fox River
Michael comments an armed robbery which
results in him being sentenced to Fork
server in prison Michael befriends the
prison Doctor Sarah
T when he pretends to
suffer from type 1 diabetes in order to
gain daily access to the prison's
infirmary where he receives his daily
insulation shots the brother's fight
toward of the execution is aided by
their lifelong friend Veronica do
Donovan who begins to invest investigate
the
conspirac that put lincol in jail
however they are hindered by covert
agents members of an organization called
the company so the company was
responsible for forming lincol and they
didn't so because of Lincoln's father
ELO Bur and his former connection with
the companies the brothers along with
six
inmates Fernando
secure Theodor TC bewell Benjamin miles
cot
Franklin David twinner apz John ab bruzi
and Charles Hayward
Pik pic who come to be known as the Fox
River eight Escape in the season P pen
might P it made Episode by using their
prison privilege to dig an escape tunnel
underneath the
prison the second season begins 8 hours
after the Escape focusing mainly on the
eight
escapes the fugitives splits up and
journey to location across the country
with
authorities close behind them as they
each Purge their their individual calls
Brad Bellic gets fired from the prison
where he worked at the main guard and
chases after the inate imate himself for
the reward money several of The Escapist
reun in search of a large cage of money
buried Long Ago by other Fox River I
made Charles West
Morland federal agent Alexander
Mone Mayon is assigned to track down and
capture the eight fidget Vis but it's
revealed to be working for the company
which wants all eight men dead when
Sarah discovers her father's Governor
Frank
tanky has been killed she miss with
Michael reminding with him as the
brothers try to break down now president
rainolds a company
member to en ensure the brothers safety
SAR allows herself to be arrested and
faces Trail turning the trail the
testimony of former secret service agent
Paul Colman who used to work for the
company controlled president exonerated
exonerates linol and Sarah half of
escapes are killed or
recapitate but the brothers make it to
panana Michael T and Mohan and bellik
are arrested by the
paname author and
imprisoned at the
penara federal Des
Sona so now we are at the third season
follows Michael inside Sona and Lincoln
on the outside in Pana Panama Sona is a
prison run by the inmates and guarded
only from the outside du
to a rot the year before iates are
always supplied with food and water and
or expect to disturb answer fellow I
made
independently the surrounding landscape
is monitored by armed guards who shots
and the who shots who shot sorry at the
side of iron ma escaping burs is quite
quickly contact by gron Morgan
accompanies operative who was in charge
of operation in in Panama who kidnapped
his son LJ to break James Whistler out
of
Sona
and the season follows Michael and wh's
trails in formulating an escape plan as
Michael has to deal with extreme tension
and as linol deals with the company's
operative greet
Morgan skew gets a job at the prison to
Aid Michael in his Escape Plan when
Lincoln attempts to rescue Sara and
LJ following a clue
proved by Sarah Gran claims to have
beaded Sarah and sing called ahead in a
box as a warning as the season as the
peer managed to escape along with Mahan
and another IR mate mate Louis leaving
behind several accomplishes including T
and
Bic
secures ident identity is discovered by
a prison guard and he is threw into Sona
just after the Escape LJ and sopia who
was captured for a
grun that Whistler would go with her or
treated for Whistler and Michael seeks
revenge against Gretchen for Sara
deaths the measure story line for the
four SE season is all about taking the
company down a team is put together the
brother secure Michael cell made in FKS
River
prison Mayon brand Bellic Sara and
Roland gland the T the team was put
together by Homeland Security agent
donel this season in my opinion was the
most complex the company the reason for
so many death surrounding each member of
the team was finally being take
down each member had a reason to take
down the
company each member knew someone killed
by the company in order to carry out the
company's selfish plans the season ends
with the company being taken down and
just just to say just
say just say coming to those
responsible still you feel like you have
to take a deep breathe after it all
comes to a slow the ski where Michael is
at the table about to H
over ska the company's black book and
patented ecological Technologies worth
bons in exch exchange for exageration
you can see it in his face he's tired
just as you think it's all about to go
so bad once more Michael says I'm tired
for of
running and he hands over
squa esqua his steam is
fully exate and their family family safe
everything that they had been fighting
for the past for years four years was
finally coming into insiration as a
viewer it felt good like taking a deep
breathe after test lugs or relaxed if
you were a watcher of the show you'd
know how it ends I feel like the adding
is very a p pry and be
beautiful so this is all what I want to
say thank you so much for joining us on
this episode of high school memories
it's been an incred incredible journey
and we're so glad you come along for the
ride until next time take care bye
thanks for listening hope you like
it hi everyone welcome back to our
podcast on the series called High School
memories my name is min and I will be
your host today so without further ad ad
let's dive into today's episode s and
urg on a great journey together get
ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about
Prison Break is an American television
series that originally aired from 2005
to 2009 a show was created by Paul Shing
and produced by Adin Peru Productions it
consists of Four Seasons with a total of
81 episodes Prison Break is known for
its suspenseful and action packed so
line the serious Revol around the
liberate and daring plan of Michael
scoffield played by wfor Miller to break
his wrongly accused Brother linol baros
played by Dominic brel out of prison
linol has been sentenced to death for a
crime he did not commit the murder of
the vice president's brother determined
to save his brother from the electric
chair Michael commenced a bank robber to
get himself in prisoned at the same
pentary Fox River State tant the first
season follows the rescue of linol baros
who is accused of murdering tery stman
the brother of Vice President of the
United States colon rolds Lincoln is
sentenced to death and is
incarcerated in Fox River State pentre
where he awaits his
excusion L Lincoln's brother brilliant
Su engineer m Michel Scofield is
convinced of Lin's insanes and
formulates an eliberate escape plan in
order to gain access to Fox River
Michael commenced an armed robbery which
results in him being sentenced to forx
server in prison Michael befriends the
prison Doctor Sarah
T when he pretends to
surer from type one diabets in order to
gain daily access to the prison's
infirmary where he receives his daily
insulation shots the brothers fight
toward of the execution is aided by
their lifelong friend Veronica do
Donovan who begins to inv investigate
the
conspirac that put lincol in jail
however they are hinded by covert agents
members of an organization called the
company so the company was responsible
for forming Lin and they didn't so
because of linc's Father ELO Burrows and
his former connection with the companies
the BS along with six
inmates Fernando
secure Theodor TC bewell Benjamin miles
Cote
Franklin David twinner aulis John ab
bruzi and Charles Hayward
pic pic who come to be known as the Fox
River eth Escape in the season P penit
made pen made Episode by using their
prison privilege to dig an escape tunnel
underneath the
prison the second season begins 8 hours
after the Escape focusing mainly on the
eight
escapes the fugitives splits up and
journey to location across the country
with
authorities close behind them as they
each Purge their their individual gos
Brad Bellic gets fired from the prison
where he worked at the main guard and
chases after the inate I made himself
for the reward money several of The
Escapist reunit in search of a large
cage of money buried Long Ago by other
Fox River I made Charles West
Morland Federal agent Alexander Mone
Mayon is assigned to track down and
capture the eight
fidget but it's revealed to be working
for the company which wants all eight
men dead when Sarah discovers her
father's Governor Frank
tankr has been killed she miss with
Michael reminding with him as the
brothers tried to break down now
president rolds a company
member to en ensure the brothers safety
Sor allows herself to be arrested and
faces Trail turning the trail the
testimony of former secret service at
Paul Colman who used to work for the
company controlled president exonerated
exonerates linol and Sarah half of
escapes are killed or
recaptured but the brothers make it to
panana Michael tag and Mohan and bellik
are arrested by the
PanAm authoriz and
imprisoned at the
penara federal
Desa so now we are at the third season
follows Michael inside Sona and Lincoln
on the outside in Pana Panama Sona is a
prison run by the inmates and guarded
only from the outside Duo
to a riot the year before iates are
always supplied with food and water and
are expect to disturb and ser fellow IAT
independently the surrounding landscape
is monitored by armed GS whoots and the
whoots whoot sorry at the site of iron M
escaping burs is quite quickly contact
by gron Morgan a
company's operative who was in charge of
operation in Panama who kidnapped his
son LJ to break James Whistler out of
Sona
and the season follows Michael and W's
tra in formulating an escape plan as
Michael has to deal with extreme tension
and as linol deals with the company's
operative greet
Morgan skew gets a job and the prent to
Aid Michael in his Escape Plan when
Lincoln attempts to rescue Sara and
LJ following a clue
prooof by Sarah gr claims to have Beed
Sarah and Sansing called ahead in a box
as a warning as the season ends the peer
managed to escape along with Mahon and
another IR mate in IM mate Louis leaving
behind several
accomplishes including TBC and
bag
secures ident identity is discovered by
a prison guard and he is threw into Sona
just after the Escape LJ and sopia who
was captured for a
grun that Whistler would go with her or
traded for Whistler and Michael seeks
revenge against grin for Sarah
deaths the measure storyline for the
four SE season is all about taking the
company down a team is put together the
brother secure Michael cell mate in foxy
River
prison Mayon brand Bellic Sara and
Roland gland the teaching the team was
put together by Homeland security agent
d s this season in my opinion was the
most complex the company the reason for
so many deaths surrounding each member
of the team was finally being take
down each member had a reason to take
down the
company each member knew someone killed
by the company in order to carry out the
company's selfish plans the season ends
with the company being taken down and
just just to say just
say just say coming to those
responsible still you feel like you have
to take a deep breathe after it all
comes to a slow the ski where Michael is
at the table about to hand
over ska the company's black book and
patented ecological Technologies worth
bons in exch exchange for exaggeration
you can't see it in his face he's tired
just as you think it's all about to go
bad once more Michael says I'm tired for
of
running and he hands over
squa esqua his team is
fully exited and their family family
safe everything that they had been
fighting for the past four years four
years was finally coming into f as a
viewer it felt good like taking a deep
breathe after test lugs are relaxed if
you were a watcher of the show you'd
know how it ends I feel like the adding
is very a p pretty and be
beautiful so this is all what I want to
say thank you so much for joining us on
this episode of high school memories
it's been an incred incredible journey
and we're so glad you come along for the
ride until next time take care bye bye
thanks for listening hope you like
[Music]
it